la mort de georges de flottes le meurtre
de trop on va écouter françois durpaire
spécialiste des états unis selon lui est
les manifestants américains ne veulent
et ne peuvent plus supporter ce racisme
en tout cas la situation et d'une dune
grand préoccupe beaucoup d'américains on
est passé vous rappelle du loch dorn au
bright dawn du déconfinement à cette
situation de cassure sociale est il ce
qui est dénoncé aujourd'hui et bien
c'est le fait vous savez quand vous êtes
noir aux états unis vous avez deux fois
plus de risques d'être arrêté par la
police au volant que si vous êtes blanc
et vous avez ensuite deux fois plus de
risques d'être fouillé par la police
pareil pour la justice les jurés noirs
sont beaucoup plus révoqué que luxure et
blanc et si vous êtes condamné par la
justice aux mêmes débits exactement aux
mêmes délits bien si vous êtes un homme
loire vous allez en prison
avec 20% de paix non plus que si vous
êtes un américain blanc pareil si vous
voulez faire une plainte si vous voulez
déposer plainte dans un commissariat aux
plaintes sont deux fois plus reçu si
vous êtes un américain blanc plutôt que
si vous êtes un américain noir pour
beaucoup d'américains qui souffrent du
racisme ou systémique
le vrai sujet ne sont pas les images de
violence parce que ces images de
violence passeront mais c'est la
violence du racisme qui elle ne passera
pas